escoltados por soldados bielorruso y
cientos de emigrantes se alejan de la
frontera polaca para ser trasladados en
autobuses a otro lugar según los
funcionarios la mayoría fueron llevados
a este centro de refugiados
proporcionado por minsk una aparente
señal de que el gobernante bielorruso
alexandr lukashenko estaría dispuesto a
rebajar las tensiones con la unión
europea sin embargo unas 2.000 personas
aún permanecen en la frontera cerca de
la ciudad polaca de cus nica incluso
después del cierre de su campamento
improvisado si no tomas sivok tco
terminó junto al paso fronterizo
bielorruso un grupo de migrantes montó
un campamento las tiendas de campaña
están desplegadas hay hogueras
encendidas también hay un camión
cisterna lleno de agua y las autoridades
bielorrusas estaban distribuyendo
alimentos almacenados
el traslado se produjo un día después de
que estallaran nuevos enfrentamientos
entre los migrantes y las fuerzas de
seguridad polacas los refugiados que en
su mayoría huyen de conflictos de medio
oriente no han perdido la esperanza de
llegar a europa occidental
aquí la gente se alegró de la noticia de
que belarús y la unión europea acordaron
mantener conversaciones tras una nueva
llamada telefónica entre el presidente
luca 5 y la alemana angela merkel
mientras minsk lo presentaba como un
avance diplomático bruselas insistió en
que las conversaciones se centrarán en
la ayuda humanitaria y el apoyo técnico
para repatriar a los migrantes la ub no
reconoce a lukashenko como el líder
legítimo de belarús y los diplomáticos
occidentales le han acusado de utilizar
a los migrantes como peones para
desestabilizar al bloque en represalia
por las sanciones en su contra